several months ago in this show we broke
the story of Tony Podesta's lobbying for
Ukraine Podesta of course is the founder
of the now-defunct Podesta group which
for years was one of the biggest
Democratic firms in Washington he's also
the brother of Clinton campaign chairman
John Podesta he's also a close friend
and a major fundraiser for Bill in
Hillary Clinton the Podesta group we
reported worked with Paul Manafort to
lobby on behalf of Ukrainian interests
in the United States without properly
registering at the time under the
foreign agent Registration Act which is
called fara Manafort got in big trouble
for that he's now being held in solitary
confinement he's looking at a life
sentence behind bars and Tony Podesta
whatever happened to him well tonight we
can report exclusively based on two
separate sources we spoke to today the
Tony Podesta has been offered immunity
by robert muller to testify against Paul
Manafort in other words for a near
identical crime bill and Hilary's friend
could skate and emerge completely
unscathed
while Paul Manafort may rot in jail only
one of them made the mistake of chairing
Donald Trump's presidential campaign
maybe the most amazing is the pretext
under which all of this is happening
the fara law was passed back in 1938 in
order to prevent the Nazi government
from lobbying in the US over a 50-year
period from 1990 66 to 2015 a total of
only seven people were criminally
charged under fara many more could have
been charged Washington is brimming with
unregistered foreign agents and has been
for decades and yet only seven people
were charged over 50 years and yet in
recent months three people have been
charged under fara what do they have in
common you guessed it some connection to
Donald Trump federal laws ought to be
enforced
unlike the left we actually believe that
but they must be enforced equally or
they're not laws at all their political
cuddles and tools of social control they
become illegitimate and scary this case
ought to make you nervous